there is no part of me that thinks that
was the right way
to behave Will Smith just smacked the
[ __ ] out of me
Chris I
apologize to you my behavior was
unacceptable March 27 2022 will go down
in history as one of the most shocking
moments on TV the 94th Academy Awards
served as the backdrop and the scene all
unfolded on one of entertainment's
biggest stages I want to apologize to
Chris's mother you know I wasn't
thinking but how many people got hurt in
that moment when will slap Chris he
slapped all of us but he really slapped
me
why do you say that
because when you hurt my child you hurt
me source told E.T at the time that
Chris Rock was very upset with how
everything had been handled and it all
started with this joke jaina I love you
GI Jane two can't wait to see it all
right first we'll laugh but his wife
Jaden Pinkett Smith didn't seem so
amused it was a GI Jane joke keep my
wife's name
no I'm going to okay and check out
Lupita Nyong'o shocked just like we all
were her expression later became a mean
at first you thought oh my God it's a
skit oh my God is wait a minute there's
no punch line wait whoa It's A Punch not
a punch line later that night despite
the attack will took home the best actor
Oscar and seemed defiant in his speech
I'm being called on in my life
to love people
and to protect people
and the reactions rippled through
Hollywood
I was sickened I was sickened by the
standing ovation I'd announced this
morning that I was suing will for 200
million dollars because that video is
going to be there forever okay will will
and Chris we're going to solve that like
family we're not going to take that
Oscar from him
no no no
that is the worst thing Will Smith has
ever done wait I forgot about wild wild
west
don't let your lip react and on that
fateful night during the commercial
break Denzel Washington and Tyler Perry
step into de-escalate Denzel said to me
a few minutes ago he said at your
highest moment be careful that's when
the Devil comes for you when we walked
over to him he was devastated he
couldn't believe what happened and to
get all the way to this moment of
winning Alaska that was the one of the
crowning moments of his career that he
wanted so desperately Flash Forward
months later and it doesn't seem like
Chris and will have spoken but Chris has
been on stage
[Applause]
whoa okay
now that he recently wrapped his world
tour with Dave Chappelle he's working on
a new comedy special
God
does not make
mistakes
in March the same month as the Academy
Awards he'll make history as the first
artist to perform live on Netflix seems
odd that he perfect being
would rest
as for will what has the journey been
like for you these last few months
between suffering and salvation you know
and you know it's just been a uh
beautiful a beautiful a beautiful
transformation
in December he starred in emancipation
on Apple TV plus but they never
never break me it's getting Oscar buzz
and yes will could still be nominated
but he's banned from the awards and all
Academy events for the next 10 years
love will make you do crazy things
foreign